in der engadiner bergwelt liegt das
hochalpine institut
hier lernen und wohnen schüler von nah
und fern
[Musik]
sie war aus sankt petersburg befindet
sich im letzten jahr des gymnasiums
schulkollegin matla und in scuol und
besucht die sportklasse
auch für robin aus der innerschweiz
stellen sich nun die weichen fürs leben
ein team von internet betreuer kümmert
sich um die freuden und sorgen der
jugendlichen
und gerhard stäbler amt als rektor des
traditionsreichen instituts
für alle ist es das jahr der
entscheidungen
[Musik]
es ist der tag der die sommerferien
abschließt in emmetten oberhalb des
vierwaldstättersees
robin pekings packt seine sachen um sein
letztes jahr im internat in angriff zu
nehmen
der 19 jährige lebt die meiste zeit des
jahres im hochalpinen instituts
auf 1700 meter höhe
du weißt nie was genau erwarten wir dass
man hat zwar nur gucken
was ist soll damalige
sogar glauben
sie dass es platz geholt wird und den
beruf und einer stop police und so
neben warmen pullovern packt robin auch
ungewohnte schulutensilien ein
[Musik]
nur mit einer ausnahmebewilligung der
schulleitung davor bin das messer ans
institut mitnehmen denn er benötigt es
für seine abschlussarbeit
in den ferien und an den wochenenden
wohnt robin bei seinem vater einem
engländer der seit kurzem wieder fest in
der schweiz wohnt
sieht aus als ob ich drei monate weg
wäre
eine erfolgreiche woche
robbins eltern sind geschieden bevor der
vater wieder in die schweiz zurückkehrte
arbeitete er lange in abu dhabi
[Musik]
die mutter von robin lebt in argentinien
eine weile wohnte robin bei einer
pflegefamilie
danach alleine damals besuchte er das
gymnasium instanz seine schulleistungen
verschlechterten sich bis vor einem jahr
nicht mehr ging
denn zu fertigen
alternativen bieten
und damit ihr traum
leider zieht
sie sind
um die rate
versäumt haben
essen
allerdings seien
es kostet
abstand oder
und dann ist das internet
wird die option gesehen
robbins reise führt in drei stunden ins
unterengadin
in eine kleine gemeinde mit 500
einwohnern
ein wenig oberhalb des dorfes liegt das
hochalpine institut
eines von rund 100 internaten in der
schweiz
noch ist das gebäude leer
es sind die letzten momente der ruhe
bevor die schüler eintreffen sie wählen
aus ganz unterschiedlichen gründen den
weg hier hoch seien es familiäre
umstände schulische herausforderungen
oder auch der wunsch intensiv sport
treiben zu können
[Applaus]
internat betreuerin ruth bader macht
eine letzte runde durch die zimmer
[Musik]
ruth berlau arbeitet seit drei jahren
als betreuerin im internat und ist
mutter von vier erwachsenen kindern
es sind intensive letzte stunden für sie
in denen sie das geräumige internat
herrichtet
nach zwei monaten sommerpause kehrt nun
das leben ins internet zurück
dieser unscheinbare raum ist das
herzstück des institutes das büro der
internatsleiter rothweiler teilt sich
die arbeit mit sechs anderen betreuern
von allen 63 internats bewohnern wird
ein foto gemacht
beiden neuen schülern ist das besonders
wichtig um sie schneller kennen lernen
zu können
[Applaus]
und englisch
alle neuankömmlinge sollen sich
willkommen fühlen 20 junge frauen wohnen
im mädchen trakt ein guter teil der
zimmer ist nicht besetzt
[Musik]
die schwester von
sefa pusch kind trifft ein
sera stammt aus russland genauer sankt
petersburg der 18 jährige kommt mit
seiner familie direkt von einer europa
reise ins internet
worauf wartet ihr
er ist schüler der gymnasialen
abschlussklasse
[Musik]
habe letzte klasse noch ein jahr und
dann bin ich gerechnet
die eltern von sefa suchten eine schule
in der schweiz weil sie das
bildungsniveau hier höher einschätzen
als in der heimat im alter von 15 kam
sie war nach tann nun ist er im vierten
jahr im internet
doch auch für altbekannte wie ihn gibt
es beim fototermin keine ausnahme
der leiter des internats jens bauer
übergibt den zimmerschlüssel sie warnt
welches thema er bekommt
und jungs haben das volk ist ja schon
sehr gut vorbereitet dass die halten wir
fertigen plan gebracht wo jeder name
schon eingetragen war und ich habe mich
auch durchgerungen jeden wunsch zu
erfüllen in kempten stock alles in gut
geführten sind alle gut es gibt mehr
wundert sich manchmal die schüler wollen
unbedingt ein ganz herzliches zimmer
haben
nordseite und klein und dunkel und was
weiß ich also herzlich zu machen wir
eigentlich nicht aber aber eigentlich
das schönste und da hat man sich eine
zeitlang gefragt warum wollen sie dieses
zimmer ja weil das wlan von der schule
und
im ersten stock gleich neben dem
internat büro wohnen die jüngsten buben
mit zunehmendem alter steigt man immer
höher in den stockwerken
treppensteigen ist hier quasi ein
privileg
der vater von sefa bezahlt pro jahr rund
45.000 franken für das internat davon
sehen zwei drittel schulgeld und ein
drittel ist für die unterkunft und
verpflegung
vierte letzte bin ich ganz gut dann muss
ich nicht auf ein stück zweimal bleibend
habe ich alle durch hunger strecke durch
das ist wichtig ist schulden
dann dann er muss muss oder juni gehen
nach nach universität gehen ich glaube
wir glauben
familie
das wird für uns ganz
nicht
ein aufenthalt hier oben ist stets mit
erwartungen und hoffnungen verknüpft
schließlich kostet das internat viel und
um die ecke gibt es auch nicht gerade
immer mehr schüler treffen im verlaufe
des nachmittags ein
[Musik]
robin ist erst auf halber strecke
bei einem zwischenstopp nimmt er seinen
klassenkollegen team mit
rubin ist erst zwei jahre im internet
team bereits deren sechs
die beiden besuchen die abschlussklasse
6g in einem jahr absolvieren sie die
maturaprüfung
st
cheftrainer genannten
ja
das
bad urach -
deswegen werde ich glaube so etwas
zurück
[Musik]
oben am hochalpinen institut wird ein
empfang sapporo vorbereitet
[Musik]
auf der rückseite des gebäudes nimmt er
abschied von seiner familie die trennung
fällt ihm nicht mehr so schwer wie noch
in früheren jahren
und wir sind sehr froh wenn selber zu
uns kommen nach hause nach lassen
zwar wird seine eltern nun für zwei
monate nicht mehr sehen er gehört zu der
handvoll ausländische schüler die
ständig im internat leben
robin dagegen fährt fast jedes
wochenende wieder nach hause drei
stunden hin und drei zurück
als einer der ältesten im internat hat
auch er seine bleibe selbstverständlich
im vierten stock
robina dasselbe zimmer bekommen dass er
schon vor den ferien hatte
[Musik]
es ist ein wiedersehen unter freunden
die sich nur während der schulzeit sie
danny boyle
[Musik]
rektor gerhard steuble macht sich bereit
für den empfang der schüler
stoibers engster mitarbeiter ist der
österreichische prorektor kurt leitet
seit vier jahren ist rektor steuble im
amt er legt großen wert auf einen
menschlichen umgang mit allen seinen
mitarbeitern
gleich vier stühle in der aula seine
eröffnungsrede halten
aber danken wir
aber das hat mit dem geburtenrückgang
[Applaus]
der geburtenrückgang ist etwas dass
rektor ströble umtreibt deswegen muss er
im verlauf der nächsten jahre mit
weniger schülern rechnen
jetzt mit
einige gäste kommen von weit her andere
wohnen gleich um die ecke das institut
ist nicht nur ein internat sondern auch
eine regionale schule rund die hälfte
der schüler kommt aus den umliegenden
dörfern wie etwa wien
[Musik]
was kommt auf mich zu und jetzt kann ich
stark das doch schon
der empfang ist für alle neuen schüler
und ihrer familien gedacht egal ob sie
nun im internat wohnen oder hier nur die
schule besuchen für die unterländer und
die jugendlichen aus dem ausland ist das
hochalpine institut eine privatschule
für die jugendlichen aus dem
unterengadin eine öffentliche schule
die älteren schüler sind nicht in der
aula sie war richtet sich ein und bitten
[Musik]
bei manchen dingen in seinem zimmer
erkennt man den wahren wert erst auf den
zweiten blick
das ist reines politisches nur kein
wildes auf italienisch wenn so liegt
wenn sie da steht dann sieht dass sie
das nicht und ich kann das alles kommt
sie
dem abgießen eingespielt oder
die größte spiel ist bei uns
auf den schuh schreibst wenn man das so
sieht dann kannst du sooo genau
anschauen dann schauen und dann den
schuh die ganze spiel das ist die größte
niemand merkt
auch rubin ist dabei sich einzurichten
wieder da nach acht wochen
komisch foren sind alles da um gestellt
ich mich ab oder nahmen so kann ich das
kann ich so unklar
das hatte ich glaube nicht so passt es
wieder umgestellt das heißt ich bin nach
washington um stelle trafen sich komisch
als das laufen und damit ein schönes
lied sag es geht hoch schlagen im 5 g
[Musik]
sie war macht einen ausflug rüber in den
mädchen trakt wir schauen ob seine
freundin jasmina schon hier ist
die beiden sind seit anderthalb jahren
ein paar und gehen sogar in dieselbe
klasse
die eröffnungsrede ist vorüber
rektor gerd steuber muss noch schnell
etwas in seinem büro erledigen während
sich die gäste bereits zum apero begeben
unter die gäste mischte sich auch ein
überschaubarer anlass in familiärer
atmosphäre
das hochalpine institut fan ist bemüht
um einen persönlichen umgang die frau
geld nicht da kinder vorhanden ich immer
gesagt
wir sind nicht
konfliktfrei schulen nicht der ideale
schüler aber was ich ihnen versprechen
ist egal ob er dem einzelnen und mit
namen das kind
wichtig das ist nicht einfach zum 24 24
problem macht dann ist nicht nur die 420
ikonisches weg
sondern
grundverständnis die chance kriegt man
eine familie söhnen pfeil gemacht und
kenne zu hüten aus so eine anlage wie
man das aber bringt und wenn wir das
sind für andere und es
ist toll atego jetzt die
politisch ist mit der junge menschen
genau mit dem motor dahinter
gerhard strobel steht in einem
spannungsfeld von ansprüchen denen er
gerecht werden muss
denn in diesem altehrwürdigen gebäude
treffen gegensätze aufeinander städte
und bauernkinder finanziell schwache und
vermögende leistungssportler und hänger
hochbegabte und lernschwache ihnen allen
gerecht zu werden ist hohe schule
insbesondere für die internats betreuer
internatsleiter jens bauer begibt sich
in die vierte etage zur stockwerks
besprechung
neun junge männer wohnen im vierten
stock alle mindestens 18 jahre alt
[Musik]
die sitzung findet ihn robbins thema
statt welches er bereits umgestellt hat
ich will einfach dass der förderstopp
auch ein bisschen vorbildwirkung halt
von jeglicher beziehung christopher was
machst du das geschafft ist dann müssen
die älteste und alles und sie ist die
älteste meistens am meisten schnee das
muss nicht so sein und falls ja ist mir
von de mail ist immer gesagt wurde das
ist alles immer nur die zweite und
dritte stock und ist dritter stock im
formular logisch
also haben die volks ja recht gehabt
dass ihr den meisten scheiß gebaut also
muss ich doch ständig bei euch auf dem
vierten stock sein und aufpassen
gleichzeitig treten im mädchen trakt
muss ich auch ein paar jungs neugierig
rumtreiben
jbl versucht ordnung in die zimmer zu
bringen
[Musik]
es keiner geschafft
das
okay so zieht
und dann komme ich zur nächsten frage
wer vermisst ein von euch im kühlschrank
so dass das wahr zu sein also soviel der
kühlschränke habe ich nicht aber dann
zeige ich euch mal nachher warum es
keinen kühlschrank auf dem zimmer gibt
ein grund hier zeige ich euch dann aber
ich habe hier oben bald auf den auf der
flur gespielt
fletcher den kühlschrank aufgemacht wir
haben drei tage gelüftet und dem nie
wieder rauszukriegen und es klingt es
steht jetzt eine plastiktüte eingehüllt
unten im video shop könnt ihr euch noch
gedanken machen was alles was jetzt
gemacht und
[Musik]
es ist widerlich und genau aus diesem
grund weil es widerlich ist gibt es kein
geschockt das ist der beweis dass es
nicht funktionieren
auch im mädchen trakt wird nicht alles
bewilligt
[Musik]
die betreuer möchten von der türe aus
direkt aufs beziehen können
[Musik]
der kühlschrank wird besichtigt sieben
wochen war er ohne strom gefüllt mit
esswaren versteckt hinter einem haufen
möbel
das kann man glaube ich nicht mehr
haben
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
erst
machst du dann bis freitag gedanken wie
das ding nach hause bringt
[Musik]
bald beginnt die erste nacht eines
langen schuljahres
bis um mitternacht sind jeweils zwei
erwachsene betreuer anwesend
danach nur noch einer für die
nachtschicht der
morgen bricht an über dem hochalpinen
institut
in der rechten hälfte des gebäudes
befinden sich die schulzimmer in der
runden mitte die aula und im linken teil
des hauses die zimmer der bogen
lange wohnten hier die mädchen denn bis
vor 20 jahren war es ein reines
mädcheninternat die schule hieß damals
noch hochalpines töchter institut nun
wohnen die schülerinnen ein wenig zurück
versetzt im neubau ganz außen befindet
sich schließlich der sport trakt mit
turnhalle und konditions- raum das
hochalpine institut ist eine von fünf
anerkannten sportschulen von swiss
olympic der bekannteste ehemalige
schüler ist olympiasieger dario cologna
der vier jahre hier im internat lebte
betreuerin fletcher war für die erste
nachtschicht im internat eingeteilt er
ist ursprünglich neuseeländer lebt aber
schon lange in der region
es waren ereignis arme stunden
grant fletcher macht sich auf die runde
er kennt seine pappenheimer die gerne
verschlafen
rowling genommen
wer weiß schon dass er um acht uhr
new york kurz nach sie nicht um macht
und zahler vorsichtig dann grüne legen
auf den beeten
okay
die schüler können wählen ob sie ein
einzelzimmer oder ein doppelzimmer
belegen wollen die mehrheit von ihnen
möchte alleine wohnen
durch den verbindungsgang geht grant
fletcher in den mädchen trakt
[Musik]
katar ist
da war ich schon acht uhr in der aula
oder
ok ok ja lena und ich schlaf wenn er das
habe ich mir gedacht okay
die alena
art und es
ist schon vor ort gelingen
okay
dass ich
zurückkommen
stehst auf ok sie später
[Musik]
um acht uhr findet in der aula eine
erneute ansprache statt diesmal nur für
die internatsschüler uran fletcher hat
sie alle aufgeweckt
[Musik]
dies sind alle mehr oder weniger in
spielberg
ist die trade das ist für dich war
aber es war durch und so wird das ganze
ja
das glaube ich nicht
ein paar kilometer unterhalb des
institutes im alten dorfkern von spielen
hier macht sich eine weitere schülerin
der abschlussklasse bereit für das neue
schuljahr
die 19 jährige model einer guidance
denn einfach noch
mal einer wohnt hier gemeinsam mit ihrem
vater einem arzt im ruhestand
mutter und schwester leben weiterhin in
der nähe von chur
kleiner hatte auch dort ins gymnasium
gehen können aber sie entschied sich für
das hochalpine institut
kleiner hat eine behinderung die ihr das
kann erschwert
das rechte bein ist nicht richtig
gewachsen und deutlich kürzer als das
linke
gleichwohl ist sport die große passion
von mal einer im hochalpinen institut
besucht sie die sportklasse mit
schwerpunkt langlauf firma kleiner
beginnt nun das letzte schuljahr
froh dass man alles hinter sich den hut
nimmt sich noch einmal gas das
denkmal
um das kürzere bein auszugleichen trägt
man alleine am rechten unterschenkel
eine prothese
[Musik]
fünf minuten braucht man kleiner zu fuß
zur busstation von school
von dort aus fährt jeweils mit dem
postauto nach tann in die schule
[Musik]
in diesem bus sind nur schüler vom
hochalpinen instituts
sie kommen aus kleinen orten wie nah
oder ramos und ihrer muttersprache ist
rätoromanisch
70 jugendliche aus der region besuchen
das hochalpine ist die tochter sei es im
gymnasium in der sekundarschule oder in
der handels- und fachmittelschule die
kosten für sie übernimmt der kanton
die aller erste schulstunde im
abschlussjahr beginnt
klassenlehrer mario zankl heißt die
schüler der 6 gb kommt
jetzt müsst ihr mir bevor wir uns
begrüßen sagen wo
die abschlussklasse besteht aus 16
schüler die hälfte davon wohnt im
internet die sogenannten internen
die andere hälfte stammt aus dem
unterengadin die sogenannte externe
begrüßen zum letzten schuljahr hier am
stück und ihr habt die letzten
schulferien letzten sieben freien wochen
hinter euch und hoffentlich gut
überstanden ja und da möchte ich gleich
zum
allerwichtigsten kommen das wäre was das
wichtigste für mich sagen in den
nächsten paar wochen
jetzt habt ihr viel gemacht
fast fertig da habe ich mir gedacht gut
zu fahren mit 17 aus mit den arbeiten
wenn ich so fragte bei dir 0 was heißt
das dann ja ich habe euch lieb
ist
und dann vorgeworfen frage dann bist du
noch nicht so richtig
hat du hast den zeitplan mit dem coach
gesprochen und so kriegt das hin locke
man leider richtig gut
aufgehoben sind das heißt mast würde ich
auch nachfragen darf
dann genug
zeit für das ja
bei dir und
und dann ist irgendwann
motorrad wenn ihr jetzt ein flaues
gefühl in der magengegend hat wenn ihr
an die matura denkt dann kann ich euch
nur ans herz legen nutzt die zeit in
diesem jahr schafft euch einen polster
während der beiden während des ersten
semesters während des kurzen zweiten
semesters dann müsst ihr vor der matura
nicht ausrechnen was für noten jahr
haben dürfte damit sich eine vier
ausgeht und was ihr nicht und wo ja noch
eine viertel note herd bekommt also
schaut dass ihr das alles rechtzeitig
kind bekommt dann könnt ihr euch auf die
matura sogar freuen würde sein
die hungrigste jungs zuvorderst
[Musik]
die essensausgabe gleich deine raubtier
fütterung
die küchenmannschaft bereitet täglich
drei hauptmahlzeiten zu außerdem gibt es
noch einen sony am morgen einen sphäre
und einen spät land niemand soll hier
oben hunger leiden müssen
robin muss früher gehen denn er hat eine
besprechung
er begibt sich dafür ins büro von
prorektor leitl und
[Musik]
leite lebt im tirol und pendelt jeden
tag eine stunde nach tann robin hat sich
den prorektor als betreuer seiner matura
arbeit ausgesucht und orientiert die nun
über den stand der dinge
rubin hat als thema survival überleben
in der wildnis gewählt
das ist das mini mitnehmen ewald treml
sache dass ein tisch maße dass das nicht
schon mal blut
das ist
magnesium block der steuer mit dem wir
die wir machen und so und den
mittelpunkt das sind zum laufen bringen
in seiner kleinen schönheitsfehler dass
ich das mache
das wird dann so sieht dass ihr die
kraft hat dann war das ein dasein die
sind gleich hoch und dann ist das auch
wieder tiefere und dann leg ich das weg
wer konstruktion diagonale herr denn was
mir wichtig ist dass man das halt mit
fünf tage will robin ganz alleine im
wald verbringen und sich nur von dem
ernähren was er dort findet bären und
heuschrecken
seine erlebnisse ergänzt mit
fachliteratur
verarbeitet er in einem bericht
diese matura arbeit ist zwingend um das
gymnasium abschließen zu können
für robin ist es ein entscheidendes jahr
wie schon für hunderte von schülern vor
ihm jeder jugendliche erlebt an diesem
ort seine persönliche geschichte und ist
gleichzeitig nur ein weiteres glied in
der immer länger werdenden kette von
jungen menschen die in den letzten 200
jahren das institut besucht haben
von einer ehemaligen schülerin hat
rektor steuble ein foto erhalten von
und den pastoren ganze volk von manchen
und spüren natürlich auch dann für mich
selber der ausspruch ich an der schule
wie trust bauer sich eine
weiterentwickelte fit machen für zukunft
und das ist das ist das wo nicht immer
wieder als persönliche großer vorteil
empfindet dass ich an sage
war das darf nicht unterbrochen werden
also muss im worte job mache damit dass
tatsachen wieder
[Musik]
die schülerinnen und schüler haben sich
verändert über die jahrzehnte
die aufgabe des hochalpinen institutes
jedoch ist dieselbe geblieben
jungen menschen eine ausbildung zu
bieten und ihnen eine zweite heimat zu
geben
voller zuversicht und hoffnung staaten
die jugendlichen in das neue schuljahr
während weiteren fünf folgen werden wir
sie nun begleiten durch den herbst
winter und frühling noch ahnen die
schüler nicht dass es unerwartet
ereignisreiche monate werden nicht bei
allen reichen die kräfte um ans ziel zu
kommen und selbst die institutsleitung
sieht sich unverhofft mit
ausserordentlichen problemen
konfrontiert
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge der
internatsschule macht sich jeder so an
seine aufgaben
[Musik]
gemeinsam mit ihrem konditionstrainer
bereitet sich mal einer auf ihr großes
ziel vor den engadiner frauenlauf
machen
rektor gerhard steuble brütet über den
finanzen
und alleine im wald ernährt sich robin
von heuschrecken
oder einzelner füße kommt
[Musik]
naja